GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIVE AND
NOT LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS. AND IT HERE TO A
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AS WE COMPLY WITH
THOSE ORDERS WERE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. COOPER ALSO LIVE
STREAMING THE HEARING TODAY SO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OTHER
MEMBERS AND STAFF MAY FOLLOW
ALONG FROM A DISTANCE SAFE
DISTANCE. AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYONE OUT THERE TODAY'S
HEARING CONSISTS ONLY OF ITEM
CENTER SUSPENSE FILE. ALL OF
THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA THIS
MORNING HAVE ALREADY HAD A
HEARING PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS
COMMITTEE. WHERE THE PUBLIC HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER BOTH-
BEFORE RUSSIAN MEDIA OPPOSE AND
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. AS NOTED IN
THE DAILY FILE AS A SENSE THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING. IS A
VOTE ONLY HEARING THEY'LL BE NO
TESTIMONY AND THEY'LL BE NO
DISCUSSION. OF THE TIME FOR
THAT DISCUSSION WAS DURING THE
HEARINGS. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY FELLOW MEMBERS THEIR
STAFF. THE APPROPRIATIONS MY
STAFF EVERYONE WHO HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO GET US TO THIS
POINT. IT WAS A LOT OF HARD
WORK UNDER EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES THANK YOU ONE.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE A SPECIAL
THANK YOU TO OUR VICE CHAIR THE
SPACE. AND HER FOR SCHOOL STAFF
AS WELL FOR THEIR COOPERATION
AND COLLABORATION THROUGH THIS
VERY DIFFICULT YEARS WELL. I
WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT WE HAVE TWO OF OUR MEMBERS
WHO WERE THE SYSTEM FINALLY AND
SENATE ONE A VERY SPECIAL HERE.
YEAH I USED TO HERE ARE JUST A
HILL YEAH. JUST MISTER HELLO
TURNED OUT SUCH A MISSED HILL
TO SERVE ALL EIGHT ON COMMITTEE
SO ALL THE SO I TO SET YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE I THE SKIMMER MR.
PICTURE MISTER WALKER SHERRY BE
BACK NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU NOT
GOING ANYWHERE THANK ANYWHERE.
THAT SOUNDED LIKE YOU'RE SORRY
THAT IS TO BE BACK NEXT YEAR SO
A COUPLE THINGS. WE WILL
PROCEED- TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC EVERYONE KNOWS THIS IS
THE PROCEDURE. WE WILL BE
MOVING QUICKLY THROUGH THE
AGENDA ALPHABETICALLY IN
AUTHOR- BY AUTHOR'S NAME.
PLEASE PLAY CLOSE ATTENTION AS
WE WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING THE
MEMBERS THAT WILL BE UP FOR A
VOTE THIS MORNING. IF YOU DON'T
HEAR ME TAKE UP A PARTICULAR
MEASURE THAT BILL WILL BE HELD
UNDER SUBMISSION. I WILL
ANNOUNCE THE AUTHOR THE
MEASURE. AND PROVIDE A BRIEF
DESCRIPTION OF ANY AMENDMENTS
TO THE MEASURE BEFORE WE TAKE
THE VOTE WE WILL BE TAKING A
ROLL CALL ON EACH MEASURE.
FOLLOWING THE HEARING. WE WILL
BE POSTING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
VOLUNTEER WITH THE POSTING.
RESULTS AND THE ACTIONS TAKEN
ON EACH MEASURE. ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AT W. W. DOT. S. A. P.
R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT G. O.
V. SO IT'S W. W. DOT. S. A. P.
R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GOP SO
IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING AT HOME AND
YOU DON'T WRITE. AS FAST AS WE
DO BUSINESS YOU CAN GET A-
POLICE REPORT AFTER THE
COMMITTEE. IS DONE WITH ITS
BUSINESS ON OUR WEBSITE. IN
ADDITION FOR ANY BILLS THAT ARE
AMENDED TODAY. WILL BE HOSTING
ADDENDUM ANALYSIS. CHECKS
PROBABLY SHOULD POSTING IT HAVE
A DENIM ALICE'S WHICH INCLUDES
A SUMMARY OF THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE REVISED FISCAL IMPACTS-
IMPLICATED BY THOSE AMENDMENTS.
CHAU MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM PORTANTINO. I'M HERE
UNTIL HERE BATES HERE IT'S HERE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE HILL
YOU'RE STILL HERE JONES JONES
HERE LEYVA. LEYVA HERE MY
COUNTY PETER ASK HERE. FOR WE
HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE. HOLD ON
ONE SECOND. ALL RIGHT OUR FIRST
AUTHOR IS AGUIAR-CURRY. AND WE
HAVE EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY.
COMMUNICATIONS CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND THE
MOTION IS A MAN PER AUTHOR WITH
TO DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS
FOR OFFICE TO CLARIFY BALL
FUNDING PROJECTS MUST PROVIDE
FUTURE READY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AMEND TO CONFORM ACTION TAKEN
ON SB ELEVEN THIRTY RELATED TO
THE SURCHARGE. MEASURES
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA I'D BATES NO BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES KNOWS
LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY BY
THE CASKEY I. ADDRESS FIVE
LOADS. MEASURES OUT FIVE VOTES.
WE MOVE ON TO THE SECOND ITEM
OF THE YEAR AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT AND STATE AGENCIES
MEETINGS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO
STRIKE THE TIME FRAME
REQUIREMENTS FOR POSTING
MEETING MATERIALS. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ZERO TWO EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. I
YOU KNOW I BATES NOT LOADING.
IT'S LOADING BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL I FEEL BY JONES. LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI HAI
CASKEY I. FIVE ZERO. OKAY THE
PROPOSAL. WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
KAONS A. B. TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE ON COUNTY JAILS
RECIDIVISM THAT IS A TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR EIGHT
THREE MEASURES TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO FIVE
MEDINA I BATES NO BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL HI JONES JONES ARE LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI KELSEY
I. SIXTY ONE. OPPOSE OUT SIX TO
ONE. THE TO MR BERMAN. AB
SEVENTY ON CALIFORNIA PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A MAN SPOKE WITH A
MAN'S PER AUTHOR TO PROVIDE A
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION IN.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES AYE BATES
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL
AYE HILL AYE JONES JONES AYE
LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
CASKEY R. IT'S SEVEN ZERO. ZERO
SEVEN ZERO. WILL MOVE ON TO AB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT FOUR BY MR
BERMAN THE COUCH STATE LOTTERY
REVENUE ALLOCATION THAT IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO. I FORTINO AYE
BATES. NO BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE PHIL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA. AYE LEYVA
I WHAT CASTING HI CASCADE BY
FIVE TO SIR. BILLS ARE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE AS RECESS SO EVERY
HOLD ON.
ALL RIGHT
WE ARE BACK FROM OUR RECESS. WE
MOVED TO MISTER BIGELOW AB
TWENTY FORTY ON PROPERTY TAX
ALLOCATION COUNTY OF MADERA.
THIS IS A TO PASS WITH THE
MANAGED TO REVISE THE SCHEDULE
FOR THE RAF TRANSFERS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FORTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI TINA I
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL. AYE JONES
JONES I LEYVA WAIVER ARMOR
COUNTY. HI DUSKY ARE. SEVEN
ROADS THE BILL OUT APRIL WE
WILL MOVE TO MISTER BLOOM. AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND RCF
VI'S- THIS IS A TO PASS WITH A
MEMBER WITH A MEMBER AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. TO MAY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. I'M SORRY
THESE ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS USE
ME. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTIES
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX IS DUE
PASSED WITH A MAN'S TO DELAY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO MAY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
HI TINA I BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES I LEYVA I
BELIEVE I WOULD COUNTY HI
CASKEY BY BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES.
RIGHT TO RESIDENTS WELLS. TO
MOVE ON TO MISTER BLUM AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ON
PESTICIDE USE OF ANTI
COAGULANTS. RECOMMENDATION ö
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR O CLARIFY CDFW IS
OVERSIGHT OF CD PR REVIEW ALLOW
ACCESS FOR AGENCIES AND CLARIFY
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXEMPTION. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY HILL HI
BILL HI JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI MAKOWSKI HI THE CASKET
BY. DOES. FIVE TO TWO. FIVE TO.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
BOERNER HORVATH AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WORK SHARING PLANS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO
INCREASE THE THRESHOLD FOR
PARTIAL UNEPLOYMENT BENEFITS
AND MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES.
SENATE BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES JOHNSON
LEYVA I LEYVA AYE MY COUNTY I
CASKEY BY. BACK TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TWO ONE. WILL MOVE
TO AB NINETEEN FORTY NINE AND
CARLSBAD FISH HATCHERY THERE
ARE AMENDMENTS TO SUNSET THE
PROGRAM IN SEVEN YEARS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN FORTY NINE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HI
BILL HI JONES JONES AYE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI. HI
ESCAPAR. SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN
ZERO. WILL MOVE TO MR BONTA A.
B. SEVEN THIRTY TWO ON
INCARCERATED PREGNANT PERSONS
AND IT IS A MOMENT THAT TO PASS
FOR THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED TO
STRIKE SEGREGATED CONFINEMENT
AND OTHER PROVISIONS REVISED
PRENATAL CARE PROVISIONS.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTY TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI UNTIL I BATES AYE
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES JON
SNOW LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI CASKEY BY. SIX TO
ONE. BUT IS OUT SIX TO ONE.
WILL MOVE ON TO HIS BURKE. AB
EIGHT FORTY SIX PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT PEACE OFFICERS THAT
IS A TO PASS. MOTION ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY SIX THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES BY LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WIECKOWSKI HI FENSKE BY.
SEVENTY ZERO. DOLLARS OUT
SEVENTY WILL MOVE ON TO BURKE
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN ON
INCOME TAX FEDERAL CARE SACK
LOAN FORGIVENESS. OF THIS IS
DUE PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THE MOTION. IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN. BATES I.
BRADFORD AYE HILL I'VE HILL AYE.
JONES I LEYVA. HI LAKE IOWA CAL
AYE I CAN BY. SEVEN IS A-
CHAPTER WAS OUT SO TWO ZERO.
WILL MOVE TO A BEACH FOUR OH
FIVE RIGHT TO SAFETY SEVEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DESERVE TO
PASS WITH THE MAN'S TO DELETE
LOCAL MANDATE AND SIMPLIFY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. SENATE
BILL TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO I BATES BATES
NOW BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL
AYE HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
MAKOWSKI ARE. FIVE TWO SIX FIVE
TWO TWO. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT ON OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH HAZARDS IS A DO
PASSED WITH A MAN'S PER AUTHORS
TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
EXTEND EDITION OF PROTECTIONS
AGAINST EMPLOYER RETALIATION TO
DOMESTIC WORKERS. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
NOW BRADFORD BRADFORD BY HILL
HILL HI JONES JONES NO LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY CASKET HI
CASKEY ARE. IT'S. FIVE TO. FIVE
TO TWO THAT WAS TWENTY FIVE OH
FOUR. THAT WAS TWENTY FIVE SIX
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
SIX FIFTIES TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT IS OUT FRONT. FIVE TWO.
FIVE TWO OKAY MOVING TO MISTER
CALDERON. AB FIVE EIGHTEEN
SURPLUS STATE REAL PROPERTY
SOUTHERN YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
PERCEPTION CENTER AND CLINIC IS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL FIVE
JONES JONES NOW LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WIECKOWSKI HI MY COUNTY ARE.
LOWS FIVE TO. HOSE OUT FIVE TO
TWO. AND COULD IN THE FISCAL
ALSO AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE ON
RECREATIONAL WAVE BASINS. THAT
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. BY
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES ARE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
MAKOWSKI HI. THAT'S SEVEN TWO
ZERO IT WAS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO.
MISTER CALDERON AB TWO THOUSAND
FOUR ON MEDICAL TEST RESULTS
VERIFICATION CREDENTIALS WITH
THE MEMONS MOTION IS TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR. TO
MOVE THE WORKING GROUP TO GOV
OPS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND
AND FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. BY PORTANTINO AYE
BATES VOTING. BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HILL HI BILL HI JONES JONES
BY LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY
HI CASKEY HI. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO
THAT WAS AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
WRECKED ALL RIGHT. MOVING TO
MISS CARILLO AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE. IT IS A MOVE TO
PASS WITH THE MEMBERS TO STRIKE
THE WORKGROUP. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
FIVE PORTANTINO FIVE STATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL HI BILL HI JONES.
JONES HI LEYVA HI FAVOR HI MY
COUNTY HI CASKEY ARE. SEVEN
ZERO THERE OUT. SEVEN ZERO. YOU
GUYS WOULD HOLD ON FOR SECOND
GONNA TAKE A QUICK BREAK.
ALL
RIGHT WE'RE BACK. WE MOVED TO
CERVANTES. AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN ON REGIONAL BUSINESS
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK PILOT
PROGRAM. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS ON THE MEDIA REGIONAL
HOUSING OPTIONS THIS TRAINING
CENTER THERE I WAS DISTRACTED
PILOT PROJECT THE MOTION IS. DO
PASSED WITH A MAN'S FOR AUTHOR
TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATIONS MAKE
PARTICIPATION IN THE PILOT
PROGRAM SUBJECT. OPTIONAL AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. HI TINA FIVE BATES
BATES I. BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HELLO HI JONES JONES PLAY LEYVA
I MY COUNTY HI CASKEY ARE. SIX
TWO ZERO SEVEN SOUTH SIXTY ZERO
MOVE ON TO SURVIVE A TWO SIX
LOS. ON CRIMINAL SUPER LEAD
FILE THE MOTION TO DO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BUILT SIX ZERO THE
MOST IS TO PASS THIS FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI. TINA ARBEJDE.
ALL RIGHT BATES ARE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I HILL HI HILL AYE
JONES. JONES BY LATE. HI LEYVA
BY WHITE. HI THE CASKET. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THAT IS SEVEN
ZERO. CERVANTES TWENTY THIRTY
ON PARA TRANSIT. THE MOTION IS
TO DO PASS WITH THEM FOR AUTHOR.
TO REVISE THE DEFINITION OF A
CHASE IN COUNTY A MAN ALSO TO
OFF. IT AND WE'RE- A J. COUNTY
AGREEMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
THIRTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
AMENDED TO SENATE FOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD ON
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI JONES
HI JOE BY LATE I LEYVA MY
COUNTY HI CAL BY. SEVEN ZERO AS
OUT SEVEN IS. WILL MOVE ON TO
MY CHIU. AB FOR THIRTY SIX.
RIGHT PAYMENT TO FALL MORTGAGE
FOR. AND RELY TO CO WITH NINE.
AND IS A TO PASS RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY SIX
THE MOST IS TO PAY TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FORTY. I TINA FIVE
DAYS. BATES NO BRAD. SEVEN ON
THE ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITY
CLOSURES. IT IS A TO PASS WITH
THE MEN'S FOR AUTHORED TO
REQUIRE A LICENSED REPORTS
SPECIFIED INFORMATION AND
EXTEND RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL
PROVISIONS. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I'D BATES. OKAY
BATES NO BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES JONES
NO LEYVA BY A HI MY COUNTY HI
CASKEY. FIVE THOSE. FIVE TO
TWO. THOSE OUT FIVE TO REMOVE
TO AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
ON ON HANDGUNS IS A DEEP
RECOMMENDATION. AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVEN CHIU THE MOTION IS THE
PASS THE SAN FLOOR. PORTANTINO
I WANT TO KNOW I BAY. BATES NOW
BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY. STILL BY
JONES JONES WAY HI LEYVA I
CASKEY HI KELSEY ARE. IT'S TO
BUY TWO TWO OR GONNA TAKE A
SHORT. K. WERE RESET. VETERANS.
RIGHT MISTER BRADFORD HERE MR
WHITE CASKET HERE MR HILLS HERE
MISS LIVES HERE MISTER JONES
HERE RESPECT THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA PHONES WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO. AB NINE. SIXTY THREE. ON
MANDATED REPORTERS THEY DO PASS
MR SECRETARY YOU GOOD YES
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I. FIVE BATES
BATES AYE BRADFORD. RATCHFORD
I'D- HILL I ENJOY. JR I'D LEYVA.
LEYVA BY CAL SKI BY CAL SKI ARE.
LOS ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. WE WILL TO MAKE COOPER AB
SIX SIX FOUR ON WORKERS COMP
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIX FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO ONE NINETEEN OH FIVE
BATES LOADING IT'S NOT VOTING
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
BILL JONES. THE FOURTEENTH
LEYVA I LEYVA WHITE HOUSE BY
OKAY BY. ITS FIVE TO ZERO THOSE
OUT. FIVE ZERO. WE WILL MOVE TO
MISTER MISTER DALY HAS A FOR
THREE FOUR ON HOW FIND FOR
UNIVERSE APPLICATION. MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO SEPARATE HOMEOWNER
AND RENTAL PORTIONS OF THE TEO
DE PROGRAM. REMOVED DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR CHANGES TO
BE BIOLOGY PROGRAM AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES MR SECRETARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY FOUR
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. I
PORTANTINO I BATES. BATES FIVE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES BY LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
ACCOUNTS HI WELL SEVEN ZERO.
DOLLARS OUT. SEVENTY ZERO. DALY
A TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN ON
INSURANCE MARKETS ACTION PLANS.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE THE
COMMISSIONER TO STUDY AND
REPORT ON THE CREATION OF AN
IMF PROGRAM OVERSTEPPED REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. ON THE
CREATION OF AN IMF PROGRAM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO ALL RIGHT BATES.
BATES BY BRADFORD RIGHT
BRADFORD HI AYE HILL AYE JONES.
JONES LEYVA I LEYVA AYE MY
CASTING. CASKEY ARE. SEVEN ZERO
FIVE DOLLARS OUT ZERO. WILL
MOVE TO DATE AB THREE OH FIVE
THREE ON THE LABOR COMMISSION
ON PAY WAGE CLAIMS AS A DO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ZERO FIVE
THREE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SAN FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO FIVE BATES. BATES
BRADFORD BRAD HI AYE HILL BY
JONES JONES FIVE LEYVA HI LEYVA
BY WHITE BY CASKEY ARE. SEVEN
BUT BILLS. SEVEN TO ZERO. WELL
MOVE ON TO EGGMAN A NINETEEN
SIX MENTAL HEALTH. AND THAT IS
A DO WITH A PER AUTHOR CORRECT
CROSS REFERENCE. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I AM TINA ALL
RIGHT BATES. YEAH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE NINE SEVEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. BATES HI
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL
EARLY HILL AYE JONES JR BY LATE
I LAY I LIKE AYE THE CASKEY.
FIVE SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
AS A- EGGMAN AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHT SEVEN ON THIS WASTE
PLASTIC PRODUCTS CERTIFICATION.
IF MOTION IS DUE WITH A MAN FOR
AUTHORED REQUIRE PLYMOUTH
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AMENDMENTS
TO SPECIFY THAT THE RECYCLING
BIT REQUIREMENT FOR PARK PRICE
AFTER JANUARY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I
YOU KNOW I BATES. BATES HI
BRADFORD. FOR DIE HILL I HILL
HI JONES. JONES VOTING LEYVA I
LEYVA AYE WHAT HI CAL ARE. SIX
TWO ZERO THAT WAS OUR SIX DOES.
MR FONG A. B. TWO THOUSAND SO.
STATE HIGHWAY RELINQUISHMENT
STATE HIGHWAY ROUTE ONE EIGHTY
FOUR IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I WANT TO KNOW I'D
BATES BATES HI. BRADFORD AYE
HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES JONES I
LEYVA I LEYVA HI MY HI KENTUCKY.
FIVE SEVEN ZERO. SOUTH SEVENTY
ZERO IN REGARD TO FRAZIER IN
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSIT. A
MULTIPLE TRAIN ISSUES IS A B.
TWO TWO EIGHTY FIVE. THERE IS
TO PASS WITH THE TO THE LEADS
THE CAN TO APPROPRIATE ARE R.
A. INTEREST. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FIVE MOST TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO ON THE TEAM ALL
RIGHT BATES. BATES BY BRADFORD
OR BRADFORD AYE HILL FILL HI
JOE. JONES BY HI LEAVE HI MIKE
HI CASKEY ARE. LOTUS OF ZERO A
BILLS OUT SO ZERO. WILL BE TO
MISS FRIEDMAN A TWO SEVENS. ONE
PERSON INCOME TO QUALIFY EMPLOY
PLAN LOW RELATIONS THE CARE.
THE CITY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIX
MO TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES BATES FIVE BRADFORD BRAD
AYE HILL HI HILL AYE. J. I HI
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI ESCAPE.
BUT SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
IS. ALSO IS FRIEDMAN A. B.
SEVENTY ON FOSTER YOUTH. IT A
DEEP PASS WITH AMENDMENTS OFF
TO MAKE THE PLACE PAYMENT
PERMISSIVE AND REQUIRED THE- TO
ISSUE FIVE. GUIDE USED.
ASSEMBLY JAVA ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE SEVEN NINE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE SENATE
PORTANTINO I TINA I. STATES HI
BROWN. BRADFORD I HILL AYE HILL
BY JONES J. FIVE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA BY WHAT HI MAKOWSKI ARE.
IS SET TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATIONS. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE ZERO SEVEN FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO BATES. IT'S NOT
VOTING BRADFORD BRADFORD HI
HILLS HIGH HILL HI JONES JONES
I LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY
HI MAKOWSKI ARE. FORTY SIX TWO
ZERO THE BILLS OUT SIX ZERO
ALSO BY MISTREATMENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN A. B. THIRTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR ON FIRE
PREVENTION- WILDFIRE RISK
MODELS. AND THE MOTION IS TO DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO SUNSET THE BILL IN
FOUR YEARS AND AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATIONS. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOURTH MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO BATES. BATES FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL BY JONES JONES I LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY KOSCIELNY MAKOWSKI
BY. THIS IS A ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING TO MR
GABRIEL AB. TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN ON GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. THE MOTION
IS TO DO PASSED MR SECRETARY
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
ONLINE WHEN TINA ALL RIGHT
BATES. BATES FIVE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES AREN'T LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI KANSKE
ARE. LOTUS ZERO THAT BILLS OUT
TO ZERO. ALSO BY GABRIEL AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX ON
FUNDING ACCOUNTABILITY AND WAS
THIS. THAT RECOMMENDATION OF
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH AN
AMENDMENT TO ADD A CO AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I'M FORTINO FIVE
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES FIVE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WHY CASKEY HI CASKEY
FIVE. SEVEN ZERO. THAT WAS OUT
OF SEVEN TO ZERO. MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA AB NINE NINE
FIVE ON HAZARDOUS WASTE. IT IS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE NINE FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
FIVE BATES LOADING PAGE NOT
FOUND IN. BRADFORD EFFORT HI
HILLS HIGH HILL HI JONES JONES
NO LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY
AYE MAKOWSKI. LOTUS. FIVE TO
ONE. APRIL IS OUT ON ONE SECOND.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE.
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA A. B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN ON BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON LITHIUM
EXTRACTION IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE TO PASS RECOMMENDATION MR
SECRETARY WHICH CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. HI
TINA ARE BATES FELT BATES NOW
BRADFORD. EFFORT I HILL HI HILL
BY JONES. JONES ROAD LEYVA AYE.
LEYVA BYE BYE KASKY HIGH
CASCADE BY. IT IS. FIVE TO ONE.
THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE TWO ONE.
ALL RIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE ON
DIMETHYL ETHER DME BLEND AND
USE FOR FUEL TAX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX SIXTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. I CONTINUE HI BATES.
EIGHT FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES.
JONES FIVE LEYVA AYE LEYVA BY
MY COUNT I MIKE ARE THIRTY
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO YES THAT
WAS OUT. SEVEN ZERO. MOVING TO
MISTER GIPSON. AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX ON PEACE OFFICERS USE OF
FORCE. MOTION IS TO DO PASS MR
SECRETARY WHICH CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. PAGE NOT
VOTING BRADFORD FOR FIVE HILL
RIGHT HILL HI JONES JONES NO
LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
MAKOWSKI BY. BOB IS. FIVE TO
ONE. BUT BILLS OUT FIVE ONE
ALSO BY MR GIPSON AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE ON INVASION OF
PRIVACY FIRST RESPONDERS. IT IS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO FIVE
FIFTEEN OH FIVE BATES BATES
FIVE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
HILL HI BILL HI JONES. JONES
I'D LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WHY
CASKEY HI MY COUNTY BY. WHAT IS
SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
SEVEN TWO ZERO. ALL RIGHTS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AB
SIXTY SIX POLICE USE OF FORCE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO EXEMPTS
CDC ARE LIMIT CHEMICAL AGENT
PROVISIONS CHANGE REPORTING
PROVISIONS AND REQUIRE
ALTERNATIVE GUIDELINES. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO HI BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. HILL HI BILL HI JONES
JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI MY CASKEY FIVE. DON'T
CALL WILL HE WILL CALL THE ROLL
OPEN ON THAT MISTER BRADFORD
STEPPED OUT FOR SECOND THE
WHOLE THE ROLE ON TV SIXTY SIX.
WE REMOVED AB ONE NINETY SIX.
ALSO BY MS GONZALEZ ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERT NINETEEN
ESSENTIAL OCCUPATIONS AND
INDUSTRIES VISIT TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
BY BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD.
HELLO HI HILL AYE JONES JONES
KNOWS WHAT LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
WHY CASKEY HI I. CASKEY FIVE.
FOR BUSH BRADFORD STILL OUTSIDE.
THAT BILL ENOUGH VOTES TO PASS
BUT WILL HOLD OPEN FOR MISTER
BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT HE JUST GOT
ME ONLINE. WE WILL GO TO MISS
GONZALEZ AGAIN ON A BE TURNING
SIXTY SIX THIS IS ON
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS PAYABLE COLLECTIONS.
IT IS A NEW PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND STRIKE
MAXIMUM PRESUMPTION LANGUAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY SIX THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. HELLO HI HILL BY
JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI MAKOWSKI. FIVE
WE WILL KEEP THAT OPEN UP THAT
ROLE OPEN FOR MISTER BRADFORD
QUE WE MOVE ON AB. TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. PILOT PROGRAM FOR
INCREASED ACCESS TO RESPONSIBLE
SMALL DOLLAR LOANS. THAT IS A
TO PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL FIVE
JONES JONES HI LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY ARE.
SEVEN TO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN ON WORKERS CLASSIFICATION
EMPLOYEE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. OCCUPATIONS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ADD AND-
OF SPECIFIED EXEMPTIONS AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THE BILL SKIMMING SEN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO I
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI JONES
JONES FIVE LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI ASKI ARE. SEVEN ZERO.
BUT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO MS
GONZALEZ ON AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE DENSITY BONUS LAW
INCENTIVES AND- INCENTIVES THIS
IS A TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHOR TO EXEMPTS CITIES
THAT PROVIDE DENSITY BONUSES
ABOVE CURRENT LAW. AND A
MENSTRUAL REVISED CONCESSIONS
AND DENSITY BONUS SCHEDULES.
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH THOSE
MOMENTS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL. HILL HI
JONES. JONES NOT VOTING LEYVA
HI HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY ARE.
IT IS FIVE TO ONE. THE BILL IS
OUT. WITH TO MS GONZALEZ A. B.
THIRTY FIFTY SIX ON A WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO SPECIFY LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ZERO FIVE
SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD BY HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY. CASCADE PARK.
WHAT IS. FIVE TWO. THAT IS FIVE
TO HOLD ON ONE SECOND. REYES.
WHERE WAS I POSTCARDS. WE JUST
FINISHED. THREE ZERO FIVE SIX
THREE ZERO FIVE SIX. OKAY WE
WILL MOVE TO GONZALEZ AB THREE
OH SEVENTY FIVE WAGE
ENFORCEMENT. AND THAT IS A DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE ZERO SEVEN FIVE THE
pMOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. I
PORTANTINO FIVE BATES. W. IT'S
NOT LOADING BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL BY JONES
JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI CASKEY BY. FIVE TO
ONE THAT DOES NOT FIVE TWO ONE
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND OPEN
LOW ROLE ON- WAS IT AB SIXTY
SIX. PERCENT OF AB SIXTY SIX
GONZALEZ RIGHT YES RIGHT. AB
SIXTY SIX MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD BUY. PHOTO
IS FIVE TWO TWO SO THAT IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO THAT THERE WAS ALSO
A B. ONE NINETY SIX I BELIEVE.
THAT'S CORRECT WAS OPEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI.
POSTS FIVE TO TWO FELLOWS ONE
MORE RIGHT CORRECT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO A. B. TEN SIXTY SIX
ON UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS PAYABLE COLLECTION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD BY. VOTERS FIVE TWO
FIVE TWO TWO THOSE WERE THE
THREE RIGHT PRACTICES OKAY SO
THERE'S NOTHING ON THE CALL
CORRECT. RIGHT MARK THAT'S
CORRECT NOTHING ON CALL. WE
HAVE FINISH MS GONZALEZ WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A BREAK NOT A
RECESS A BREAK SO YOU ALL CAN
GRAB A CUP OF COFFEE GET A BY
YOU KNOW TO TAKE A SHORT BREAK.
THANK YOU. SO WE RECESSED THE
MEETING AND TAKE A BREAK. HOUSE
SHORTER SHORT.
ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE HOPE
EVERYBODY ENJOYED THEIR BREAK
TIME. MARK I BELIEVE WE
FINISHED WITH. MARK. YEAH WE
ARE ON MISTER GRAY. MR GRAY HAS
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR ON
HORSE RACING SAFETY AND WELFARE
JOCKEYS IT'S A DO PASS
AMENDMENT. S. BILL SEVENTY FOUR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL I JONES JONES HI WHITE
HOUSE- LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI MAKOWSKY ICE. FOR ME
A VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO. AT IS
OUT TO ZERO. WE WILL MOVE TO
MISTER GRAYSON AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ON AIR AMBULANCE SERVICE.
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
REMEMBER OR DO PASSED MOTIONS
MR SECRETARY. WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AND WE BUILT
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI YOU KNOW
ALL RIGHT BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD ON BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL HI JONES JONES FIVE LEYVA
HI LEYVA AYE COUNTY HI THANK
YOU I. THIRTY SEVEN ZERO AND
OUT SOME DISEASE. WE WILL MOVE
TO MR HOLDEN AB NINE SEVEN NINE
ON CORPORATE BOARDS. ONCE. OKAY
ON CORPORATE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
IN UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
IT IS A MOTION TO PASS WITH A
MAN'S. PER AUTHOR TED CO
AUTHORS AND MODIFY REPORT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
DEMANDS TO INCLUDE. COMMITTEE
MEN'S TO INCLUDE LGBT
INDIVIDUALS AS OF UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITY. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SEVEN NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI TINA
ALL RIGHT BATES. IT'S NO
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL BY JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY NOT VOTING.
THE VOTE IS. FOUR TWO TWO. THE
BILL IS OUT FOR TWO. WE WILL
MOVE TO MS IRWIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AB. TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ON PROPERTY TAXATION
DAMAGE OR DESTROY PROPERTY
PROPERTY IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO FIVE
PORTANTINO ART BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL
HI JONES JONES HI LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY
ARE SEVEN ZERO AFTER WAS OUT
SEVEN ZERO- FOR WIND COMMITTEE
ON VETERANS AFFAIRS AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY TWO ONE GOVERNOR'S
MILITARY COUNCIL IS A TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO ALL RIGHT HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE HILL
AYE HILL AYE JONES JONES ARE
LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY I
CASCADE BY. SEVEN ZERO. THE
BILL HAS OUT SEVEN ZERO. I WE
WILL MOVE TO JOE SAWYER. AB
FIFTEEN TO FIVE ON CANNABIS
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS IT IS A
MOTION TO MOVED TO THE ASSEMBLY
CENTER FOR WITH AMENDMENTS TO
AUTHORIZE A PERSON TO WITHDRAW
WAIVER AND SPECIFIED THAT A
LICENSING AGENCY MUST STOP
SHARING INFORMATION WHEN A
WAIVER IS WITHDRAWN. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL
AYE HILL BY JONES JONES FIVE
LEYVA AYE LEYVA ARE MICHALSKI
HI ASK OUR- SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN
ZERO THAT WAS OUT. WE WILL MOVE
TO AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE ON
FALSE REPORTS AND HARASSMENT-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT NON
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA AYE BATES. HI FATES FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES I JONES R. LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY
ARE. SEVEN ZERO. THE BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO WILL MOVE TO JONES
SAWYER AB THIRTY FORTY THREE ON
CORRECTIONS CONFIDENTIAL CALLS.
THAT IS A DO PASS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
FORTY THREE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY HILL HI
HILL HI JONES HI JONES FIVE
LEYVA HI LEYVA BY MY COUNT SKI
HI CASKEY ARE. SEVEN ZERO.
APPLE IS OUT. SEVEN ZERO WE
WILL MOVE TO MISTER KALRA. AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN EMPLOYMENT
VIOLATIONS COMPLAINTS IT IS A
STRAIGHT DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN THE
MOTION S TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I BATES. BATES NOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD FIVE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MICHALSKI AYE CASKEY ARE.
POLICE TO TWO APPELLATE OUT
FIVE TO MOVE ON TO MISTER KALRA
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN ON
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO TO DO
POTATO TO PASS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO EIN
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES KNOWN
LEYVA HI LEYVA BY COUNTY HI
CASKEY ARE. THE VOTE IS TO TWO.
THE BILL OUT FIVE TO. OF TO A
TWENTY FIVE TWO AND CREEK
PROCESS DISCRIMINATION IT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO LOOK
TO LEAD TO LIMIT THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL AND AMENDMENTS TO
LIMIT. THE APPLICATION ACACIA'S
TWO CASES FOR WHICH JUDGMENT
HAS NOT BEEN ENTERED BEFORE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I BATES. BATES NOW
BRADFORD. F. R. DIE HILL HI
BILL HI JONES JON SNOW LEYVA HI
LEYVA BYE BYE CASKEY HI CASKEY
ARE. PHOTOS FIVE TWO AT THOSE
OUT FIVE TO MISTER KALRA HAS AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN ON
UNEMPLOYMENT WERE HIRING AND
RETENTION STATE OF EMERGENCY-
IT IS TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO
ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO MAKE
SPECIFIED OFFERS TO LAID OFF
EMPLOYEES REDUCE. EMPLOYEE
RESPONSE TIME FRAME AND MAKE
CLARIFYING MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND AMENDMENTS TO
STRIKE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. PORTANTINO HI
THE PAST USE ME TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO HI
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY ARE.
LOWS FIVE TO TWO. PEPPERELL IS
OUT FIVE TO TWO WE WILL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM LONGER. AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE BENEFITS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO ADD A CO AUTHOR AND
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE CONTINGENT
UPON APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN NINETY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. ALL RIGHT
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES. JONES
NO LEYVA. HI LEYVA BYE BYE
CASKEY BY CASKEY ARE. SIX ONE
THAT FILLS OUT SIX TO ONE WE
MOVED TO CALM LONGER AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR ON EMERGENCY
SERVICES COMMUNITY RESPONSE
GRANT PROGRAM IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
THE ROLE SKEWS ME ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. FIVE EIGHT FIVE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HI BILL
ONLINE JONES. AS I LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI WIECKOWSKI HI KANSKE
FIVE. HAVE SO ZERO. WEBER OUT
SEVEN WAS MOVING MUSLIM AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE ON FIRE ARMS
INSPECTIONS THE MOTION IS A TO
PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIXTY ONE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO ON
TINO I BATES. PUTTING IT'S NOT
PROVIDING BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL I FEEL AYE JONES. JONES NO
LEYVA I LEYVA AYE CASKEY CASKEY
ARE. FIVE TO ONE. THE BILL IS A
FIVE TWO ONE MOVING TO MISSOULA
AB TWENTY THIRTEEN OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICE MODEL
GUIDELINES IT IS A MOTION TO DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TED CO AUTHORS TO LEAD
REFERENCE AND AUTHORIZED
ENROLLMENT INTO AN EMERGENCY
WARNING SYSTEMS MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES EIGHT FIVE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HI
HILL HI JONES. JONES HI LEYVA
AYE LEYVA BYE BYE CASKEY HI
CASKEY R. SEVENTY ZERO AT BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO. WE WILL MOVE TO
MISTER LOWE. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN- ON REFUGEE REFUGEE.
ASYLUM EASE AND IMMIGRANT
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING IT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE. JONES FINALLY HI THEY
ARE A WHITE HOUSE GIVE I CASKEY.
FIVE AT SEVEN. SEVEN ZERO
PHYLLIS OUT AB TWENTY TWO A
EIGHT NURSE STATE OF AMER.
RECOMMENDED IS A OR MOTION TO
PASS WITH A MAN FOR ALL A MY IN
PERSON CLINICAL REQUIREMENTS
AND DELETE SIMULATION
AUTHORIZATION AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES FIVE
BRADFORD. EFFORT HI HILL AYE
HILL BY JONES I'VE JONES HI
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MAKOWSKI
AYE KANSKE R. SEVEN ZERO. AFTER
WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO WILL GO TO
LOW AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
PUBLIC TRANSIT EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS RELATED TO
BART AND THAT IS A DO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. WELL
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL AYE HILL BY JONES JONES NO
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WHITE HOUSE
KING HI CASCADE BY LOTUS. FIVE
TWO TWO FIVE TWO TWO. MOVING ON
THE MISTER MAIENSCHEIN AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR HEALTH PLANS
EXEMPTIONS. THAT IS A TO PASS
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND WE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA I BATES. BATES NOW
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA
HI LEYVA FIVE ONE CASCADE HIGH
CASCADE. FIVE IS FIVE TO. THAT
WAS OUT TO TWO MOVE TO MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN AB TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ON MISUSE OF SPERM AND
OVUM OR EMBRYOS IT IS A D. PASS
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY FOURTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
FOR. I AND TINA ARE BATES FIVE
SIX FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HI FIVE. JONES FIVE I THEY
AYE MY COUNTY HI CASKEY BY.
THAT IS SEVEN ZERO. I BILLS OUT
SEVEN IS MOVING AGAIN THE
MISTER MAN A TWO THREE SO UNTIL
MATURE AND MY HEALTH IT IS A
DEEP. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THREE
SIXTY MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FOR BOARD. I WOULD HAI
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD BY HILL HI. HILL HI
JONES JONES NO LEYVA I THIS HI
MY COUNTY HI CASKEY BY. FIFTY
FIVE TO. BUDGET FIVE FIVE TWO
TWO SIX WEBER WAS. FIVE TO. ALL
RIGHT MOVING MISTER MAYES.
MISTER MAYES AS AB FOUR NINE
NINE ON SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
AND STATE AGENCIES MOTION IS TO
BE PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
ADD AN EXEMPTION TO REQUEST
ONE'S OWN INFORMATION AND
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE AGENCY
MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINE NINE
MOTIONS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
HI TINA ALL RIGHT BATES. BATES
AYE BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD
I HILL. AYE HILL AYE JONES.
JONES FIVE LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
MY COUNTY AYE CASKEY AYE.
SEVENTY ABALOS SEVEN ZERO. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO MISTER
MUCH. THANK THOSE WHICH COME
MISTER A. B. C. FOUR SIX ON
ELECTION VOTER ALLEN. BUT IT'S
AN PASS. SOME BILLS. FORCE
MOTIONS TO PASS SENATE
PORTANTINO. FIVE PORTANTINO
EIGHT. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HI BILL I
JONES JONES NO LES. HI LEYVA
AYE FOR KENTUCKY HI CAN BY.
FIVE TWO TWO. BUT THOSE OUT
FIVE TWO THE CARD AB OH SIX
POLICE USE OF. TO DO PASS A
MOTION TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TERRY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SKEWS ME ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN OH SIX MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. FIVE PORTANTINO BY
BATES. PAGE NOT LOADING
BRADFORD EFFORT HI HILL HI BILL
FIVE JONES JON SNOW LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI CASCADE HIGH CASCADE
BY VOTERS. FIVE TO ONE. HOLD ON
ONE SECOND. ALL RIGHT THAT WAS
OF FIFTEEN OH SIX RIGHT BROKEN
LOS FIND ONE OUT FIVE TO ONE
MOVING TO MCCARTY AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO PAROLE
INTEGRATION CREDITS MOTIONS TO
PASS OF THE CENTER FOR WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED A STRIKE
THE PROHIBITION ON WAIVER
CREDITS AMEND TO CHANGE CERTAIN
CREDITS. AND DOUBLE JOIN
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROVISIONS TO ANOTHER BILL. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO FIVE
BATES. WELL BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HI BILL HI
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA LEYVA HI
MY CASKEY HI KANSKE R. S. FIVE
TO TWO THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. MOVING TO MR MEDINA AB
THREE THREE ONE ON ETHNIC
STUDIES GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. IT IS A TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION MAKE THE BILL A
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATIONS
SAFEGUARDS REGARDING THE
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATE NOUS OF
THE CURRICULUM AND ALLOW
EXISTING. ATG COURSES- AND- THE
CLOSEST AGED THREE COURSES AND
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE A CHARTER
SCHOOL GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
PROVISION. AND IN CREASE LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY. THAT IS A TO PASS
TO THE CENTER FOR. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THREE ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
NINETEEN OH FIVE BATES. IT'S
NOT BUILDING BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE IT'LL AYE JONES
JONES KNOWN LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
CASKEY HI FAUSKE BY. IS FIVE TO
ONE THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO
ONE. THE MOVING TO MISTER
MULLIN AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
THAT IS A TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FOR WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO EXEMPT SPECIFIED INFORMATION
UNDER HIPAA C. M. I. A. OR THE
COMMON RULE. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN THIRTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO ON
UNTIL I BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL. HI
SKEWS ME HILL HI JONES JONES BY
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
KANSKE. L. SEVEN ZERO OF THOSE
OUT SEVENTY ZERO. AB TWENTY
NINE SAN FRANCISCO B. C. D. C.
MISTER MARLAND AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH NINE AND THAT IS A DO PASS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT OH
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I YOU
KNOW I'D BATES. BATES HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL HI JONES. JONES BY LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
CASKEY. PROCESS ZERO. THE BILL
IS. FABULOUS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO
LEVINE TO MISTER MURATSUCHI AB
THREE TWENTY SIX ON ELECTRIC
MOBILITY MANUFACTURERS IT IS A
DO PASS TO THE SENATE FOR WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO DELETE
THE DMB PERMITTING AND PENALTY
PROVISIONS AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWENTY SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE DINO AYE BATES.
NO IT'S NO BRADFORD. BRADFORD
NOT VOTING HELLO I STILL AYE
JONES. JONES NO. LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY I KANSKE R.
VOTERS. TWO TO. THE BILL ITSELF
FORTY WE HAVE A B. ALSO BY MR
MERCER CHU AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO ONE FIREARMS DEALERS
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FOR WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHORED A SPECIFIED FINES ARE
DEPOSITED INTO THE DRUGS
ACCOUNT. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD BY FRED AYE HILL ALL
PHIL I. JONES NO LEYVA. I LEYVA
BY MY COUNTY HI KANSKE R. VOTE
IS. FIVE TO TWO. THAT IS OUT.
FOR TO TWO. TO ALLOW AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO RIGHT WRECKED
OKAY MOVING TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO ON TOXIC FREE
COSMETICS MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR WITH A MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR REMOVE THE
PERMITTING PROCESS. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA I BATES AYE BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL HI
BILL ART JONES. JONES AREN'T
LEYVA. AYE LEYVA AYE MICHALSKI
AYE KANSKE FIVE. SEVEN ZERO.
SAMPLES OUT SEVEN ZERO THE
MOVING TO MISTER NAZARIAN AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE ON
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY
VISIT TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO SUNSET IN ONE YEAR. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
ARE. YOU KNOW FIVE BATES. BATES
AYE BRADFORD. TRAFFORD FIVE
HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES JONES I
LEYVA AYE LEYVA PINE CASKEY HI
MAKOWSKI ARE. SEVEN ZERO. THAT
GOES OUT SEVEN ZERO. MOVING TO
MR OBERNOLTE AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY ON HAZARDOUS WASTE
TRANSPORTATION CONSOLIDATED
MANIFESTING PROCEDURES IT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
TWENTY MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI TINA
ALL RIGHT BATES AYE BATES BY
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES ARE LEYVA
I LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
MAKOWSKI ARE. LOS ZERO A POST
OUT SO ZERO. MOVING THE MYSTERY.
A TWENTY SEVENTH FIVE PUBLIC
WORKS PREVAILING WAGES A MAN
FOR AUTHOR TO EXCLUDE CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH EIGHTY OR FEWER
STUDENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR ORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. TRAFFORD BY HILL HI
BILL HI JONES JON SNOW LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
CASCADE PARK. THIS. FIVE TWO.
THAT IS OUT FIVE TO MOVING TO
PETRIE-NORRIS AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES IT IS A TO
PASS A MOTION. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN MOTIONS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES HI JONES FIVE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI CASCADE
BY. FOUR SEVEN ZERO. THEY BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING ALSO TO
PETRIE-NORRIS AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO ONE STATE HIGHWAY
ROUTE ONE THIRTY THREE
RELINQUISHMENT SAID TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI TINA
ALL RIGHT BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES ARE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA I'M WORKING ON HI
FELT KEEP BY. VOTERS. SEVEN
ZERO. THOSE OUT SEVENTY. MOVING
TO MISTER COURT. AB FOURTEEN
EIGHT CANNABIST LABORATORY. IT
IS A DEEP PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES KNOWS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI MAKOWSKI
ARE. THE VOTE IS FIVE TO TWO.
COOPER WAS OUT FIVE TO COURT AB
TWENTY TWO SEP NOT TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX ON OVERSIGHT OF
SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS TO
DO PASS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL BY
JONES JONES NOW LEYVA AYE LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY BAR. IS
FIVE TO TWO. THAT IS OUT FIVE
TO TWO MOVING ON TO AB EIGHT
HUNDRED CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN IT IS A TO PASS. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED THE
VOTE THE BEST MOTION SKEWS ME
AS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES FIVE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JON SNOW LEYVA. AYE
LEYVA AYE COUNTY HI CASKEY AYE.
IS SIX TO ONE. THOSE OUTSIDE TO
ONE. COURT AB TWENTY EIGHT HOW
ON CLIMATE CHANGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING OF THE
TO DO PASS THAT'S THE BILL WE
JUST HOURS AGO WE JUST AND I'M
SORRY BONTA BURKE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY-
ON UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
AND PESTICIDE WORKERS. AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE TINA AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES.
JONES II LEYVA. AYE LEYVA ARE
LIKE ASKING HI CASKEY ARE.
SEVEN ZERO. CLOSE OUT SEVEN
ZERO MOVING TO MISTER RAMOS AB
TWO SEVEN FIVE NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE FOR CULTURAL
PRESERVATION IS A D. PASS
MOTION. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN
FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO PINE
TINA ALL RIGHT BATES. BATES
FIVE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
HILL HI HILL AYE JONES JONES HI
LEYVA AYE LEYVA FIVE WE CASKEY
CASKEY- SEVEN ZERO SEVEN TWO
ZERO MOVING ON AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION- TO DO PASSED WITH
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
THE BILL CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION MAKE WORKLOAD
OBSERVABLE AND ADD CO AUTHORS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO FIVE BATES. BATES
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL
AYE HILL HI. HI JONES HI LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI HI
CASKEY. THIS ZERO. I BILLS OUT
SEVENTY MOVING ONTO AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TRIBAL ISSUES IT IS A
D. PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
NINETY NINE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD DODD AYE
HILL AYE. AYE JONES HI JONES
FIVE LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
KASKI. CASKEY FIVE. SEVEN ZERO
IF THOSE OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING
TO. MISSOURI S. A. B. SIX
EIGHTY FIVE COVERT EXPOSURE
NOTIFICATION- THE MOTION IS TO
DO PASS OF THE CENTER FOR WITH
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED A
RECENT REDUCE EMPLOYERS
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT AND
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHT FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO HI BATES. IT'S NO
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL HI JONES NO JONES NO LEYVA.
HI LEYVA AYE MICHALSKI AYE
CASCADE. POTUS FIVE TO TWO. THE
BOAT FIVE TO THE BILL IS OUT
OVER ONE'S AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN ON INMATE HAND CREWS AS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. FIVE
PORTANTINO I BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HIGH
KASKI FIVE. LOTUS FIVE TO TWO.
AND VOTERS FIVE TWO TWO. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX MEDIC
COW BLOOD LEAD SCREENING TESTS
IT IS A TO PASS WITH A MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED REMOVED MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE MONITORING SYSTEM
PROVISIONS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO SEVENTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES I LEYVA HI LEYVA
ARM WORKOUTS SKI HIGH MAKOWSKI
BY SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT ALSO BY MS REYES AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR ON
REFUGEE SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI UNTIL FIVE
BATES. THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
HELLO IF BATES NOW. BRADFORD
EFFORT BY HILL HI BILL HI JONES
JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
KASKI HI CASKEY ARE VOTERS FIVE
TO TWO. AT THOSE OUT FIVE TO
TWO. WE WILL MOVE ON TO LOSE
THREE. A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE OFFICE AND HOMELESSNESS
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE FOR
WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
REQUIRE ALL CONTINUUM'S OF CARE
TO PROVIDE DATA THIS WHY SYSTEM.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
ARE WHAT COUNTS HI CASCADE BY.
LOTUS FIVE TO TWO. THE BILL IS
OUT FIVE TO TWO WILL MOVE TO-
WHAT FROM THE SENATE. THAT WAS
THREE OF US I WAS LOSE TRACK
RECORD OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ROBERT RIVAS- AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE COVERT NINETEEN RESPONSE
AB AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYMENT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE CENTER
FOR WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO ADD A CO AUTHOR AND CO
AUTHORS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FORTY THREE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO ON PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. PAGE NOT VOTING BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HI BILL HI
JONES JONES NOT VOTING LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY KASKI HI CASKEY
ARE. LOTUS TWO ZERO AT THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TO ZERO MOVING ON
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR AND
TELEHEALTH- IT IS A MOTION TO
MOVE TO THE SENATE FOR WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A SUNSET A
HUNDRED DAYS AFTER THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY HAS. ENDED ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
FIVE BRADFORD. BRADFORD HILL HI
BILL HI JONES. JONES PINE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA ALL RIGHT MAKOWSKI HI.
MY COUNTY ARE. THE SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO THAT WAS TO ONE SO
FOUR RIGHT WILL MOVE ON A BEACH
THOUSAND FIVE. LEROY ANDERSON
DAM AND RESERVOIR E. I. AREN'T
PUBLIC CONTRACTING MOTIONS TO
PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THOUSAND AND FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES FIVE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILLS HIGH HEELED
FIVE JONES JONES I LEYVA HI
LEYVA R. A. Y. CASKEY. HI
MAKOWSKI BY. IT IS SEVEN ZERO.
S. ZERO THAT WAS THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND FIVE MOVING ON TO
RODRIGUEZ AB TWENTY NINETY TWO
AMERICANS THE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYER SUBSIDIZED PROTECTIVE
GEAR. AND THAT IS A TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY TWO
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I DINO AYE
BATES WELL BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL LIFE HILL ART
JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY BY.
VOTERS FIVE TO TWO. THOSE ARE
FIVE TO TWO EVER AGREED
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT IT IS AB TWENTY ONE
OH ONE CHOOSE A TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I WANT TO KNOW
I BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
PARK BRADFORD HI. HILL AYE HILL
AYE JONES JONES HI LEYVA HI
LEYVA I MY COUNT AYE CASKEY
FIVE. THIS ZERO. FILLERS OUT
SEVEN IS RIGHT AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ACT
EMPLOYEE TERMINATIONS- FOR
DISCIPLINED PROCEDURES AND IT
IS A MOTION TO MOVE TO THE
SENATE FOR WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR. TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FOURTEEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES. BATES NOW BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO. AYE LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI ASKI OUR BODIES. FIVE
TO TWO. BUT OUT FIVE TO. WE
HAVE ALSO BY BYRON AB TWO FIVE
SEVEN PERSONAL. EQUIPMENT
HEALTH CARE EMPLOYEE. MOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE FOR THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
REQUIRE. DIR TO BOTH DETERMINE
WHETHER A PP SUPPLY CHAIN
DISRUPTION EXIST AND RECEIVE
SPECIFIED INFORMATION AND MAKE
A CLARIFYING CHANGE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE. HELLO HI HILL AYE JONES
JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA BYE
BYE CASKEY HI CASKEY BY. PHOTO
FIVE TO TWO AT THOSE OUT FIVE
TO MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY BLANCA
RUBIO AB THREE TWO THREE A
NEWSPAPER STATE AGENCY
ADVERTISING WORK STATUS THE
PENTACON. IT IS MOVE- TO THE
SENATE FOR WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO ADD CO AUTHORS AND
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN YOUR SHOES.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR YOU
KNOW. FIVE BURTON PORTANTINO BY
EIGHT FIVE BATES FIVE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JONES PART LEYVA I LEYVA
AYE WELCOME HI BECAUSE FIVE
SEVEN IS A- THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN THIS WILL MOVE TO AB
NINETEEN SIXTEEN SIX HAND GOOD
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AS A DO
PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY
SIXTY MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE PORTANTINO ON FOURTEEN I
BATES. KATE SNOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD I HAVE AYE IT'LL JONES
JONES NO LEYVA I LEYVA WHAT CAN
I CASKEY FIVE VOTERS FIVE TO
TWO. ADD PHOTOS FOR JUST TO THE
IS OUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A SURE
RECESS. EVERYBODY CAN GET A
COUPLE COFFEE.
WE ARE BACK. WE
HAVE MISTER SALAS HE HAS
MULTIPLE BILLS MISTER SALAS AB
TWELVE NINETY NINE PEACE
OFFICERS EMPLOYMENT IT IS A
DEEP PASS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I BATES AYE BATES
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL JONES. JONES I LEYVA LEYVA
I WANT HI CASKEY ARE SEVEN ZERO
I WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO MISTER
SALAS AB NINETEEN OH SIX
PREGNANT CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
DUTY ASSIGNMENT POLICY IT IS A
MOTION TO THE CENTER FOR WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED AND CO
AUTHORS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
HìNH PORTANTINO AYE BATES
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES
JONES I LEYVA FLAVOR I WOULD
COUNTY KENTUCKY I BOTH SEVEN IS.
THE BILL HAS OUT SEVEN TO SEE
MOVE ON AB FOR FIVE EMERGENCY
SERVICE FIRST RESPONDER IT
ISN'T PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL MY
FORTY FIVE MOTION TO PASS THE
SAN FLOOR POURTANT. I
PORTANTINO I BAY. BATES ARE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I'VE HE- HILL
BY JOAN. JONES I. LEYVA AYE
WHAT CAN I ASK. THAT'S. ZERO
OVER THE THAT PHYLLIS OUT
MISTER SEA HAS TH ONCE THREE ON
BIO GASES A TWO FOR. ASSEMBLY
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE MOTION
AS PASS SENATE. PORTANTINO I
WANT TO KNOW OUR BATES. BATES
ARBOR. BRADFORD AYE HILL HI
HILL AYE JONES JONES BY LABOR I
LEYVA I WANT COUNTY AYE CASKEY
ARE VOTERS SEVEN ZERO. OPPOSE
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING ME
SENDING AB EIGHT SIX AM FOOD
THIS. IT IS DO FOR THE TO
URGENT URGENCY. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SIX MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD BRANCH
AYE HILL HILL I JONES JONES NO.
LEYVA. I WAKE UP HI I CAN ARE
THAT'S. FOR TO TWO. THE BILLS
OUT FIVE TO TWO MISTER SANDY
ARE TWENTY EIGHTY TRAINS WHY
AND ACT FUND IT IS A TO PASS
WITH A MEMBER FOR OFF A CLARA
JEFF. S. BILL TWENTY TWO A
MOTIONS TO PASS AS TO THE FLOOR
POURTANT I WOULDN'T I BATES.
BATES NO PRESS. BRADFORD AYE
HILL I FEEL AYE JONES JONES NOT
ONLY I LEYVA WORKOUTS IN HIGH
CASCADA. IT IS. FIVE TO TWO.
NINETY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL ARE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA. AYE LEYVA
R. Y. CASKEY HI THE CASKET BY.
AS SIX TO ONE. BUT THOSE OUT
SIXTY ONE MOVING TO MR STONE AB
THREE SEVENTY SIX ON STUDENT
LOAN SERVICING. MOTIONS MOVES
TO THE SENATE FOR WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED AND CO
AUTHORS MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES
INCLUDING EXEMPTION FOR
FEDERALLY CHARTERED CREDIT
UNIONS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVEN SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES KNOWS LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY FIRE CASKEY
FIVE. DAYS FIVE TO TWO OF THOSE
ARE FIVE TO MOVING ON AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AM JUVENILE
POLICE RECORDS MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FOR WITH A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ALLOW
LIMITED ACCESS TO RECORDS. A
MENTAL LIMIT ACCESS FOR NO
OTHER PURPOSE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. IT'S NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL HI
BILL HI JONES. JONES KNOWS. AYE
LAKE I WORK ON. HI KANSKE BY AS
FIVE TO TWO. BUT THOSE FIVE TO
MOVE ON TO A COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY STONE BILL AB THREE
THREE SIX FOUR JUDICIARY I MEAN
THIS BILL OMNIBUS BILL. MOTION
IS TO PASS OF THE CENTER FOR
WITH A MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED A
CHANGES DEPARTMENT THAT WILL
TRANSLATE CERTAIN DOCUMENTS AND
TO EXTEND CERTAIN SUNSETS
RELATED TO A RISK ASSESSMENT
PROGRAM AND AMENDMENTS TO
STRIKE THE FISH AND GAME CODE
PROVISION AND TO EXTEND
TIMELINES AND SBTECH. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO AYE BATES. AYE
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES.
JONES FIVE LEYVA FIVE LEYVA HI
MY COUNTY HI KANSKE R. AS.
SEVEN ZERO. THIRTY MORE BILLS.
BAKER'S DOZEN. ALL RIGHT RIGHT
WING TO MR TANG AB SIXTY NINE
ON A. B. YOU CONSTRUCTION
FINANCING IS A DO PASS.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NINE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO ALL RIGHT DO YOU
KNOW I BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES NOW LEYVA
FIVE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
MAKOWSKI ARE. VOTE IS FIVE TWO
TWO. THE BILL IS ON FIVE TWO
TWO OF AB SEVEN NINETY THREE
PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT. MOVES
TO THE SENATE FLOOR WITH A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED TO
DECREASE IN THE FOR COSTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN NINETY
THREE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO EIN FORTINO FIVE
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD BY HILL HI BILL ART
JONES JONES PARK LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI HAI.
CASKEY ARE. SEVEN ZERO. BY
MOVING ON THE A. EIGHT ONE
ENERGY OF. STIMULUS BOTH OF THE
CENTER FOR WITH THE MEMBERSHIP
PRIORITIZE SCHOOLS THAT MEET
SPECIFIED CRITERIA. THE S. R.
V. E. V. R. PROGRAM. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JONES NOW LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY NOT VOTING.
HI HI BURKE OWSKI I'VE- BOAT IS
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE TO TWO THAT'S
OUT ALL RIGHT MOVING THEM IS
WALDRON AB THIRTEEN OH FOR
CALIFORNIA- REENTRY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WITH- MOVED TO THE
CENTER FOR THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED TO EXPAND THE FUNDING
SOURCE AND AMEND TO REDUCE
CREDIT AMOUNTS. FOR ME ON
WALDRON. DESCRIPTION OF WHAT
PRICE CAN. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE I'M SORRY I SKIPPED ONE.
I'M SORRY I SKIPPED CROHN'S. I
DID TO- I WROTE FIVE TO TWO IN
A WRONG COLUMN ALL RIGHT AB
TWENTY FIVE FOUR BACK TO MR
TANG AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE
ON SHELTER CRISIS DECORATIONS-
THIS MOVE TO THE CENTER FOR THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED TO REQUIRE
ORDINANCE TO MEET SPECIFIED
MINIMUM BUILDING STANDARDS AND
ADD EMERGENCY CLASS. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES. JONES HI LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE CASKEY AYE.
CASKEY AYE. BILLS AT SEVEN
ZERO. FOUR MR TANG STAFF
MUST'VE BEEN. KNOWLEDGE I
RESTRICTING STAFF. WILL BACK TO
MR. WALDRON AB THIRTEEN OH FOR
CALIFORNIA REENTRY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM- MOVED TO THE CENTER
FOR WITH A MEMBERS FOR AUTHORS
LOOK SPANNED. THE FUNDING
SOURCE AMEND TO REDUCE CREDIT
AMOUNTS. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
OH FOUR MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
BATES. AYE FADES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD FIVE HILL BY HILL TODD
JONES JONES BY LEYVA. HI LEYVA
HI MY CASTING. CASKEY ARE.
SEVENTY ZERO. ALL RIGHT WE
REMOVED MS WEBER A. B. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE LCF SUPPLEMENTAL
AND CONCENTRATION GRANTS IT IS
A DO PASS MOTION. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I'M PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JONES ARE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA ARE MAKOWSKI HI CASKEY BY
SEVEN ZERO. DOUBLE ZERO MOVING
ON AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
AND PRIVATE PRACTICES LEAVE
TIME. IS MOVED TO THE CENTER
FOR WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
CHAD CO AUTHORS. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES. PAGE
NOT VOTE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
HILL HI BILL HI JONES. JONES
NOW LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MICHALSKI
HI MAKOWSKI I SUPPOSE FIVE TO
ONE TO ONE- AB. THREE SEVEN
THREE OH SEVEN ZERO ON JURY
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES MOTIONS
PASSED TO THE CENTER FOR WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPLY TO JURY
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
SUNSET CIVIL CASE EXCLUSIONS
AND INCLUDE A SEVERABILITY
CLAUSE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL HI JONES JON SNOW LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
MAKOWSKI BY. PHOTOS FIVE TO
TWO. BOWS OUT FIVE TWO MOVING
TO AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE ASK
REPARATIONS IT IS TO PASS THE
CENTER FOR WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO CHANGE THE COMMISSION
MAKE UP TO SPECIFIED DOJ AS THE
ASSISTING AGENCY AND TO CHANGE
TERMS. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BOATING BRADFORD
BRADFORD BY HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES. JONES IS NO LEYVA. AYE
LEYVA HI CASCADE AYE CASKEY BY.
THIS FIVE TO ONE. THE BILL WAS
OUT FIVE TO ONE WE WILL MOVE TO
BE MS WICKS AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE ARENA ALLOCATIONS MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING- WITH AMENDMENT
TO PER AUTHOR TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION IN TRASH TRAPPED
DURING ISSUES. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO H PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. NO PETS NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL ALL
RIGHT JONES. JONES NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MICHALSKI AYE MAKOWSKI
BY. LOTUS FIVE TWO FIVE TO THE
CLOSE UP OF THE ON THE AB
THIRTY THIRTY NINETY TWO SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT STATURE LIMITATIONS
TO DO PASS. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY NINETY TWO MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO FIVE
BATES. IT'S NOT VOTING BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES. LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WHITE HOUSE QINGHAI
MAKOWSKI ARE THE FOLKS FIVE TO
ZERO FIVE IS A WE HAVE OUR LAST
AUTHOR AND THEN WE HAVE ONE
THING THAT I HAVE TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE FOR SO
WE'LL GET THROUGH EVERYTHING.
MISTER WHAT AB EIGHT NINETY
NURSE PRACTITIONERS PRACTICE
WITHOUT STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FOR WITH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO CLARIFY DIAGNOSTIC
PROCEDURES PERFORM OR
INTERPRETED BY MPS AND ADD A CO
AUTHOR AND AMENDMENTS PROVIDE
EXCEPTIONS AND FIGURE THIRTY.
TO THAT FOR THE B. R. AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD NOT VOTING
HILL HI BILL I JONES. JON SNOW
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI.
BYE BYE CASKEY BY THE BILL HOPE
IS FOR THE TWO. FOUR ONE FOUR
TWO TWO OR TWO OKAY- WE GO TO
MISTER WOULD AB TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED MEDIC CALIFORNIA SEE
BENEFITS IT IS MOTION TO THE
FOR WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TO REMOVE SPECIALTY DRUG SURVEY
PROVISIONS THAT AUTHORIZE D. H.
C. S. TO CREATE A DISEASE
MANAGEMENT PAYMENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE HUNDRED MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES. JONES I LEYVA I
LEYVA BY MY COUNTY HI CAL SKI
BY VOTERS SEVENTY ZERO. PHYLLIS
SEVEN ZERO SO THAT BILL IS OUT
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY WE'VE
DONE EVERYTHING THAT'S ON OUR
LIST BUT WE HAVE ONE ACTION
ITEM LEFT SO WE ARE GOING TO
RESCIND THE VOTE ON CHIU AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. THIS IS.
HOLDEN OKAY SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M GOING TO BE
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION ON AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. RIGHT SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO ORDERED AB
THIRTY FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL
BE RECONSIDERED AND NOW THE
MOTION WILL BE TO PASS A BE
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. SO THE MOTION
IS. TO PASS AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX TO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO FIVE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY
OUR GOAL IS FIVE TO TWO. SHOW
THAT BILL WAS REFERRED TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND THAT IS THE
COMPLETION OF OUR SUSPENSE
CALENDAR AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE YOUR
SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
OBVIOUSLY TO OUR STAFF AND
EVERYONE OUT THERE WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED. HM
THANK YOU FOR. YOUR I BRADFORD